it was a surprise move and a radical one
on Wednesday the Philippines interior
secretary benher abelos asked for the
resignation of all police Colonels and
Generals
it appears that there is a big problem
in our police force it appears that
there are generals and Colonels involved
in drugs it is difficult to fight a war
against illegal drugs if supposed allies
could shoot your back we need to clean
our ranks we need the trust of the
people
a series of stakes has led to the arrest
of at least two senior anti-drug
officers
feature of almost a ton of
methamphetamine
thousands of people died in the war on
drugs waged by former president Rodrigo
duterte many were sweet dealers and
Casual drug users but throughout his
six-year term duterte always claimed he
had evidence that high-ranking police
officials were also involved
admits his call for mass resignations is
a shortcut but he says only those who
are found to have links to the drug
trade will actually be let go police
leadership says they will comply but
human rights groups are concerned that
The Minister's request undermines due
process many of these Buddhist generals
I mean they have rights too I mean you
can I don't think it's fair to expect
them to abandon those rights
and there's feared that cases of abuse
by the police will be swept under the
rug we anticipate that after all of this
uh Mr Abalos might say oh but they've
resigned they're no longer in the
service okay it's closed and in that
sense that is a disservice to the
victims of the drug world
so far only a handful of cops involved
in drug war killings have been convicted
the government refuses to be subjected
to an independent probe by the
international criminal court
but rights groups say no matter what the
ICC must stay the course finding below
Al Jazeera Manila